ahora vamos a nombrar de forma
sistemática a todos los ácidos
carboxílicos digamos que tenemos por
aquí una molécula de la
forma con un doble enlace con un oxígeno
por aquí y un grupo
Oh por aquí esta definitivamente es un
ácido carboxílico porque tenemos este
grupo funcional por aquí y para nombrar
a los carboxílicos de forma sistemática
pues vamos a utilizar la forma en la que
nombramos a los alcanos alquenos y
alquinos pero le vamos a agregar unos
cuantos detalles entonces para nombrar
cualquier alcano lo que hacemos Es
Buscar la cadena más larga de carbonos
que en este caso es 1 dos 3 cu Entonces
tenemos cuatro carbonos en nuestra
cadena
but
pero en lugar de ponerle una o al final
Vamos a ponerle una terminación que
indique que se trata de un ácido
carboxílico y esa va a ser la
terminación
oico Okay y bueno también le tenemos que
poner por aquí
un
ácido Okay ponemos esta parte que denota
cómo está compuesta la cadena y luego
ácido y la termina oico para denotar que
tenemos aquí un grupo carboxilo ahora
tal vez estés pensando que deberíamos
escribir en qué número de carbono se
encuentra nuestro grupo carboxilo pero
si observas muy bien este grupo
carboxilo como este carbono tiene un dos
tres enlaces con un oxígeno solo puede
hacer un enlace con otro carbono Así es
que todos los grupos carboxilos tienen
que estar al final de la cadena y y de
hecho estos carbonos siempre los vamos a
empezar a numerar a partir del carbono
del grupo carboxilo entonces este es el
carbono uno carbono dos carbono 3 y
carbono cu ahora vamos con otro ejemplo
digamos que tenemos por aquí una
molécula con estructura de Luis
así con este carbono que tiene un doble
enlace con un oxígeno y este no es un
carbono Este es un enlace a un oxígeno
con un hidrógeno pero vamos a hacerlo
más interesante vamos a poner en este
carbono un grupo metilo Okay este
claramente es un ácido carboxílico
porque tiene su grupo carboxilo aquí
pero para nombrarlo pensamos en Cómo se
llamaría si aquí nada más tuviéramos un
carbono okay Entonces tenemos esta
cadena de carbonos que son un 2 3 cu 5
seis y ningú enlace doble así es que
tendríamos un heano
[Música]
heano pero en lugar de poner la o al
final ponemos
oico para denotar que tenemos un ácido
carboxílico Okay también ponemos por
aquí
ácido y dejé todo este espacio porque
nos faltó decir que aquí tenemos un
grupo metilo ahora para saber en qué
carbono está este grupo metilo tenemos
que numerar esta cadena de carbonos y
siempre empezamos a numerar por el
carbono del grupo carboxilo entonces
este es el carbono uno carbono dos
carbono TR carbono 4at carbono 5 y
carbono 6 Entonces el grupo metilo está
en el carbono tres así es que esto es un
tres
metil hexanoico Okay ha sido tres metil
hexanoico Bueno vamos con otro ejemplo
digamos que tenemos una molécula con
estructura de Luis de esta
forma pero que este carbono tiene un
enlace doble con un oxígeno y aquí en
lugar de que este sea un carbono es un
grupo
Oh y más aquí tenemos un doble enlace
Entonces tenemos que buscar la cadena de
carbonos más larga y empezar a numerar a
partir del carbono del grupo carboxilo
entonces este es el carbono
un
dos
4 5 6 y si así es que tenemos
un Tano No espera aquí no va esta a
porque aquí tenemos un enlace doble
Entonces aquí tenemos que poner una e de
ep teno y además todavía no estoy
poniendo la o porque en lugar de la O
vamos a poner la terminación oico para
denotar que es un ácido carboxílico pero
también tenemos que indicar En qué
carbonos está el doble enlace Okay Está
en el carbono no tres Así es que tenemos
que poner TR ept o también podríamos
poner
ft 3
eno bueno sin la o porque así estamos
indicando más que el doble enlace se
encuentra en el tercer carbono aunque
esta forma de escribirlo es más común
Entonces nos vamos a quedar con
esa y ahora sí aquí tenemos nuestro
grupo carboxilo entonces en lugar de la
o de ep teno tenemos que poner la
terminación
oico y indicar que esto es un ácido Okay
ácido tres
epoo y bueno si lo quieres decir de una
forma muy elegante a ver Tenemos aquí
este carbono y este otro carbono y cada
uno de ellos tiene un hidrógeno y un
hidrógeno pero si vemos esta parte de
cerca a ver aquí tenemos un doble enlace
entre dos carbonos tenemos por aquí un
hidrógeno por aquí tenemos el otro
hidrógeno y luego en este carbono
tenemos este grupo funcional al que
ahorita vamos a llamar grupo r Okay
Tenemos aquí a r y de este lado tenemos
este otro grupo funcional al que vamos a
llamar r prima Entonces por aquí tenemos
a r prima Y entonces Tenemos aquí el
enlace doble y estos grupos funcionales
se encuentran en extremos Opuestos
Entonces se encuentran en la posición
trans Okay Podrías tomar el ácido y
moverlo un poco para acá y poner en
itálicas O algo
parecido trans y nos queda ácido trans
TR ten noico Pero bueno Esto es solo
asumiendo que realmente dibujé aquí el
diagrama de Luis de la molécula en la
tercera dimensión Porque si por ejemplo
este pedazo de la cadena hubiera estado
por aquí Entonces ya no sería
trans